stronger is directed by David Gordon
Green and stars Jake Gyllenhaal as Jeff
Bowman a man who survived the Boston
Marathon bombing this is a true life
story of a man who lost his legs and had
to learn how to adjust to a brand new
life but it's also about how those
around him had to adjust to it as well
as his girlfriend at the time played by
Tatiana maslany it also explores the
difficulties of transitioning from a
normal person that no one knows about to
someone who because he was at the wrong
place at the wrong time is suddenly a
national hero everyone wants to shake
his hand when cops pull him over they
don't want to give him a ticket
everyone wants to talk to him everyone
wants to tell him as a hero and it makes
him uncomfortable for a while because he
doesn't feel or understand why anyone's
viewing him that way and that was
something that I wasn't expecting and it
was one of the most emotional aspects of
this film this is a gut-wrenching movie
one that really leveled me with
fantastic performances and obviously a
really inspiring story but it does fall
into some of the genre cliches of
inspirational biopics like this but it's
always a little hard to be too critical
of a film that was based off of a true
event especially one that were not too
far removed from because real life
doesn't play out like a movie arc with
characters who go through things like
we're used to seeing in a film so
sometimes the film can feel just ever so
slightly messy but it's because you're
experiencing Jeff's recovery you're
seeing what he feels what he probably
felt he gets invited to go to a Bruins
game to wave the flag and he's not sure
why he's doing it it makes him so
uncomfortable having all those eyes on
him people are approaching him wanting
to take pictures and he doesn't
understand why and one of the more
touching aspects of the film is his
relationship with his girlfriend because
they were already sort of on the ropes
before this tragedy happened and after
that that brought them back together
because she was really concerned about
him obviously but then after that fades
and the shock of that event is starting
to go away the problems arise again and
now it's even worse because he needs so
much more help and he needs to adjust to
this new
of living and so it's very powerful to
watch these two people trying to
reconnect in the middle of this horrible
tragedy Jake Gyllenhaal as usual is
incredible here his performance is one
that doesn't ask to be looked at
he is never trying to act his he just
feels like he's in the moment and
completely real it's one of the best
compliments I can ever give an actor
Tatiana maslany also equally fantastic
what I really loved about what David
Gordon greed did with this movie is the
fact that the people in Boston they
don't feel like actors now I know he
cast a lot of actual real medical staff
to be the nurses and doctors in this
film which is really cool but some of
the Boston citizens that approached him
to give him praise or to tell their
inspirational story they don't feel like
they're acting it just feels like we're
sort of a fly on the wall watching a
very emotional moment
it also doesn't shy away from talking
about the man Carlos who helped him out
of the disaster area initially which was
really touching to now there's a scene
at the end of this film at a Red Sox
game some people are coming up to Jeff
to tell him their inspirational stories
and to thank him for inspiring them I
have not been so emotionally affected by
a scene in years now sometimes I tear up
in a movie and maybe the music or the
performance or something about a moment
just clicks with me I had legitimate
real just tears streaming down my face
and I had to be I was like making an
effort to be quiet because the theater
was packed I was sobbing this movie has
a scene towards the end that just hit me
so hard and it was so inspiring and I
haven't really been able to say that
about a movie really ever that I really
truly sobbed and this film did it for me
it was beautiful
stronger is a great film it has some
genre cliches sometimes the story of
Bowman's recovery can feel a little
messy because it's not following your
traditional movie narratives where you
have some big uplifting montage where
he's trying to swim or you know like a
rocky training montage
something it takes it in a very serious
perspective and it feels sort of as I
said like you're a fly on the wall
watching these sequences and it is truly
powerful I'm gonna give stronger and a -
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I hope you check out this film
it is definitely worth your time if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]